When I grow up I wanna be an artist.
Dorothy from the Wizard of Oz.
Maybe Bill Gates, because he's got a lot of money.
A train driver, 'cause I like trains.
I'd like to be a race car driver.
A movie actor.
I wanna be a zookeeper.
A race car driver.
Spider-man!
If I win I might get a trophy.
Astronaut.
A doctor, because I'm so special.
I don't know.
I haven't decided.
A baseball player.
Either a soccer player or an artist.
Either a soccer player or a missionary.
A baseball player.
Baseball player, because you get most of the attention.
A soccer player.
A doctor.
I would like to be a doctor.
I wanna be a dentist when I grow up.
A teacher or an art teacher.
An artist.
I would be a missionary.
I'm going to be a teacher or something.
An actor.
I wanna be an artist one day.
Have lots of color.
I think I wanna be a police officer because they protect America.
A pediatrician or a vet.
I wanna be an inventor.
I wanna be a teacher when I grow up.
A hula dancer, because I have hula dance in school.